[Musique]
quick n'a pas mal de textes antisémites
sa mort lundi puis c'était bien entrer
dans la maison parce que j'utilisais un
objet qui m'est très précieux c'est une
carte du canada qui comporte surtout les
décors différents laponie mi du
territoire dans les langues autochtones
desquels on parle et qui est assez
ironique c'est que j'ai commandé sept
cas de l'université aux états unis donc
pourquoi ces précieux pour moi c'est
parce que trouver toutes ces noms de
territoire leur dans les langues
autochtones c'est quand même un gros
travail de recherche puis j'ai pas pu le
trouver au canada je les trouvais
ailleurs
mais cet objet leur est précieux pour
moi parce que justement il donnant les
langues autochtones et dialectes
autochtone sur leur propre territoire et
non possible à quel point certains des
territoires ont été nommés en français
ou en anglais par rapport au territoire
nommé par une communauté de tonnes et si
en réponse un peu
présente cet objet le à la controverse
qu'on ne put entendre à propos de saint
yan et de son interaction avec le
festival de la musique de grand baie
c'est très très chaud comme sujet parce
que on a dû parler de décolonisation des
mentalités ont du talent de
décolonisation si des processus des
politiques des lois des manières de le
faire comment justement les lois qui
protègent certaines langues en danger
comme le français au québec par exemple
maintenant aux primes d'autres langues
si on les applique à l'action on fait
abstraction justement de l'idéologie
derrière cette loi là c'est loi qui
protège la langue française c'est bien
de protéger des langues sensible sur le
territoire donné je pense est si
violente sensible ce sont des langues
autochtones qui existent sur le
territoire depuis des milliers d'années
et dont justement des lois des projets
de loi dès des politiques ont été mis en
place pour défaire ou détruire justement
c'est l'anglais je pense beaucoup plus
passionnés la loi sur les indiens
le fait que les lois d'affichage
justement se font en français en anglais
mais absolument pas en
lice n'avait où on nous annonce donc
c'est de voir à quel point certaines
lois sont mises en place pour certaines
communautés qui tu domines d'autres
communautés et une des problématiques
présentement au canada c'est que les
langues autochtones ne sont pas reconnus
comme des langues officielles de façon à
les protéger à les financer elles mêmes
de l'avant et c'est assez ironique cette
conversation le se fasse en début de
l'année 2022 qui est le début de la
décennie de l'unesco pour la protection
des langues autochtones la
reconnaissance des langues autochtones
donc pour les dix prochaines années on
va mettre de l'avant justement la
protection des langues autochtones
beaucoup de notre culture de notre
identité il ya la langue du territoire
les deux sont connectés et je pense que
c'est un endroit où on peut comprendre
cet enjeu le vii au québec puisque le
français justement le fait français
existent et veulent justement survivent
à des fonds de dominance linguistique
comme la salle des anglais et ce qui est
drôle c'est qu'on parle du français mais
on devrait parler des français des
langues française des jeux réseaux des
dialectes francophones qui existent sur
le territoire qui sont magnifiques je
dis moi je pense toujours aux cayes 1 au
pasp ailleurs aux chiens que toutes les
langues française qui existe sur
l'amérique du nord et qui sont inspirés
charente et territoires qui sont expirés
des interactions historiques connus et
qui chante à nos oreilles on trouve sur
hbo le je ne sais pas c'est possible
nouveau le poids même entendre d accent
francophone la même manière qu'on aime
rigoler quand on arrive en france et que
l'on trouve dont l'accent québécois
amusant et sympathique bien c'est la
même chose pour nous un avertissement on
aime entendre le français avec d'une
autre manière et bien c'est pareil pour
les communautés autochtones qui sont là
depuis des milliers d'années on attend
comparer nos langues ont d'abord échangé
jamais moi ce que je baysse une
interaction chemin avec des écrits de la
saskatchewan ils ont comparé certains
mots en ou moines et c'est parce qu'il y
avait tellement de monde connecté fait
que c'est là que j'ai compris que le
chemin que la langue au prix est
vraiment lié avec le comment de
territoire cool de lui-même c'était plus
territoriales que géographique cet
échange linguistique alors toute la
conversation qu'on a eu cette semaine a
vraiment décollé au tour des
interactions qui aussi inspiré par les
commentaires que j'ai pu lire en lait
par
ddm moi je voudrais sortie de certains
qu'un gars auto de parler de la
décolonisation des esprits des
décolonisations justement des pratiques
dans certains lieux culturels parce que
justement il faut se rendre compte à
quel point si on met en afrique à la
lettre on crée des moments de pression
sur d'autres communautés qui elles aussi
sont sensibles et à risques et sur leur
territoire ou d'océan
mentira pas le territoire du canada
c'est territoires autochtones ont cédé
donc dans le biais de la décolonisation
dans l'idée aussi la réconciliation
l'idée de promouvoir les langues de les
mettre de l'avant commencé à vraiment
faire du chemin et l'on prend en compte
le chemin festival de granby qui va
sûrement peut-être réaligner justement
ces politiques autour des chansons et ce
sera merveilleux moments de
réconciliation parce que ce cadre et
c'est vous c'est comme se positionner
fermement pour 2,7 pour sauver la face
va juste faire le contraire justement
est de plus en plus de festivals qui
justement ont à coeur de protéger les
langues francophones eux reconnaissent
que le même réalité existe pour les
langues autochtones et font de la place
justement aux langues qui sont nés sur
ce territoire et ça je pense que c'est
un moment de réconciliation fantastique
et je dis beaucoup et parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d' alex à ce que je veux dit ce
qui était fantastique c'était l'appui de
temps québécois francophones qu'ils
disent a pas de bon sens on peut pas
demandez à x2 pas quelque chose puis à
écrire et qu'on les dit non la fin
cette idéologie derrière la protection
de la langue du chemin
elle grandit dans un bon sens
cependant j'ai eu des enjeux ou pour
protéger les langues autochtones on
accuse les autochtones de vouloir
promouvoir l'anglais que c'est des
politiques anglophones qui veulent tuer
l'âme français et donc de faire des
détours intellectuelle pour pas vouloir
comprendre qu'il ya eu
justement
une pratique qui a servi en français
mais que présentement à cause de mon nom
en fait d un visibiliser les communautés
de tonnes faut se rend compte que bien
ils ont un impact présentement ces
langues autochtones si elles ne sont pas
en solidarité justement avec des
communautés qui ont les mêmes enjeux que
le français et c'est tellement
étrange à dire parce que là on essaie
beaucoup d'être dans l'éducation et
samian le fait fantastique manger des
vues justement tout le monde en parle et
je me suis dit mais c'est faux nez
encore en tant que communauté avec toi à
éduquer l'autre sur nous à prendre la
main à être d'en vouloir construire des
ponts alors que on devrait aussi en
commun que les gens allaient comme un
ver qui eux se sent insulté par le fait
qu'on se cabre face à des politiques qui
vont éteindre ou langue qui vous nous
demandait à 80% francophone alors que si
on leur demandait d'être à 80 %
anglophones dont le festival de musique
on peux tu dire qu'ils allaient des
manifestations dans la rue nous on n'est
pas encore à tenir la main et du qui
parler échanger et c'est fou c'est façon
on comprend sept anges le mais c'est
comme si on voulait donner préséance aux
français
sur des langues qui ont pressé en lice
deux millénaires sur des langues qui
sont venus ici donc c'est sa rencontre
on est encore toujours dans une position
d'habitude souvent on a une réponse qui
est celle du contraire de l'émission de
une réaction est là je pense que c'est
parce que le québec le canada au complet
doit se rend compte qu'une
réconciliation ça veut dire quoi dire se
rend compte qu'on a eu tort se rend
compte qu'on met en place quelque chose
qui nous fait bien nous mais qui me fait
pas du bien aux autres et ça c'est
difficile parce que le meilleur culpa ça
jamais été le fort de l'humain peu
importe la nation mais te rends compte
que plus on va tirer sa plus on va
attendre avant de donner des délais loi
qui protège une autochtone plus on va
attendre avant de donner des journées
nationales qui sont reconnues au même
titre que la saint-jean où le joker 2
donc on va attendre ça va continuer de
ramener ce problème là sur la scène et
ça va demander non seulement aux
artistes qui prennent seulement des
artistes samia ne pourrais juste faire
la musique comme n'importe quel autre
artiste mais ça impose à cet artiste de
devenir mettant un enseignant un
ambassadeur un passeur de savoir est
quelqu'un qui en plus explique super
bien commun plutôt que d'avoir des lois
qui protègent qui finance les hommes il
doit demander l'aide de sa communauté sa
grand-mère pour pouvoir lui enseigner la
niche nab et
moen et ça dit à quel point le poids la
protection des langues présentement ne
repose pas sur ce qui devrait les
gouvernements des communautés
autochtones ça représente justement
comme une communauté autochtone protège
supporter leur propre enseigne et tout
le poids la décolonisation repose encore
sur les épaules des personnes docteur
donc vous pouvez imaginer comment le
sujet et va est vaste on ne disait pas
en parler on a très peu de temps pour
les sauvegardes et donc on espère que la
conversation va s'accélérer quel
justement des moments de réconciliation
vont se créer
l'idée se rend compte qu'il n'y a pas de
on savait ce pot à corriger les erreurs
du passé justement on se garantit donc
plutôt que de lancer dans un projet
qui est négative pour toute la
communauté française
travail de support il ya du délestage
étaient nécessaires pour les artistes
qui est plus être des artistes créent
des des produits culturels fantastique
qui vont exister pendant des centaines
d'années et leur enlever la mission et
la responsabilité de protéger les
langues de les défendre dans les médias
ça serait extrêmement important donc
c'est lorsque l'appel à la cei de ripper
avec les communautés autochtones existe
au canada un peu loupé francophones et
les communautés autochtones
moi c'est lorsque j'ai eu le plus
d'inspiration c'est quand justement on
s'est rendu compte qu'on avait pas
besoin d'appareil mais quand on avait
des parallèles plutôt que d'essayer
d'effacer ce pronom écouteurs faut qu'on
protège la france est ce important de
français et qu'elle est un aveuglement
volontaire des enjeux de club parce que
c'était donc trop grand a reggae et vous
comprenez on va on est on a beaucoup de
sujets sur nos assiettes pour pouvoir
permettre aux communautés de pouvoir
aller de l'avant survivre qt
culturellement et linguistiquement et
c'est là où est ce qu'on vous demande
justement
s'il parle possible on vous manque de
pourra écouter la musique en anishinabe
d'ailleurs l'album de sagan qui est pour
moi vraiment un grand succès justement
la vie colonisation de prendre sa langue
de la prendre c'est quand même quelque
chose que je lui envie énormément parce
que pour moi c'est très difficile à
prendre nous mêmes quand je dois me
concentrer sur d'autres enjeux aussi
cette étude c'est tout un travail qui a
été fait et qui devrait être promu émile
avant je pense que il me coûte québécois
qui comprendront cet enjeu alors c'est
une belle semaine n'hésitez pas à nous
envoyer des questions et c'était pas non
plus à partager une vidéo
je sais que ça va être chaud comme sujet
je sais que voir des commentaires
est positif c'est ce que j'ai vu de plus
cette semaine et des négatifs parce
qu'il ya quand même encore du travail à
faire mais n'hésitez pas à le faire ça
nous aide beaucoup